Oh
, it's already been 10 days,
right? At
first, I thought you were a guy with a good name, but
he was finished with smoke bombs and feint attacks, so
you can rely on a woman
.  At that time, I thought it might be because my earphones were gone, but I didn't know you could
hear the sound of my slight weight shift as I moved to control the shadow.
That's the explanation, he's a
terrifyingly good ear,
and I should praise him for noticing it well, but it's blue.
Weight shift is an unconscious habit.
Rise in numbers
Shallow breathing I can understand it like I'm holding it in my hands
What if I could
ride the opponent's pace
[Music]
Daishoin
Hoshimawari-sama's son  It
's about the face shape of Konoha's mother, who turned into a human being.
I have no choice but to
do it